john great making his way to one of his
favorite spots and that is the coors
field mound he is always pitch well
in colorado and uh john will face down
the arizona diamondbacks
7-9 and 393 earned run average for john
this ball lined to center field and
hampton cruises over one out one two
swing and a missy got him with the
slider
a couple of quick ads for gray
just a nice pitch sequence you've
dropped the bottom out of your slider
you can tell the swing over the top john
just spins the baseball so well
popped him up shallow center field
hampson long run i don't know if he sees
it now he does the back starter today
the right-hander taylor widener still
gaining momentum after three stops and
starts this year in the injured list
hoping to build on that today
fastball out over the plate backs up
katel martin still backing up but he
reaches out and grabs it on the warning
track that looked like it might carry
over cattell's head out there he tracked
one down in that same spot last night
and recovered at the last moment there
today
one out in the inning now it's a
left-handed batter ryan mcmahon against
widener
and mcmahon unloads on one to deep right
center field no one's gonna catch this
one connor joe to third gets a green
light from stu cole
and the throw goes toward third
a run scoring double for mcmahon
one-nothing colorado
62nd rbi for mcmahon
that's a fastball out over the middle of
the plate that peralta runs down
rocky strike first diamondbacks trailing
one nothing
balls have been getting up in the zone
just a bit on him like that one right
there
and ellis didn't miss it he drives it to
the wall in right van meter on the move
he'll stop at third it's a double for
drew ellis
one out
second and third for dalton varsio
marshall slugs one deep to right field
it's in dalton
bullpen
and it's 3-1 diamondbacks he homers in
back-to-back games
that ball was crushed yeah it sure was
2-2 to walker
and he got him on that wicked slider
[Applause]
he gets ellis on a fastball at 96.
a couple more strikeouts for gray in the
third he's got five of those
2-2
and john comes back gets a strikeout of
far show that's his sixth of the ball
game
i like this pitch because the slider
speeds up his bat and for johnny's like
you know what i'm gonna throw a little
bit off with the curve ball a couple
miles off that pitch and get him out in
front two strike count to widener gray's
pitch swing and a miss got him on a
slider down and in and that's two
strikeouts in the inning and seven in
the game for john gray
right there with a fastball and there's
some velo at 94. rings up hilliard
and gets his second strikeout 94 painted
it right there on the outside corn
beautiful
2-2 on hampson
fastball right by him
back-to-back strikeouts now for widener
back to the power game from taylor two
outs of the fourth
well three strikeouts and two walks in
the inning for taylor widener but after
four he leads it three to one
what happened
well that's kind of what's been going on
with taylor widener
on the ground walker's got it they get
one
hey they roll it
widener hustles over to cover gets the
double play and gets through five this
would be the fourth
batter in a span of five to draw a walk
here this would force in a run obviously
[Music]
third to first
[Applause]
and he's walked in a run it's four to
one
back to back bases loaded walks by two
different pitchers and it's five to one
christian walker leads off the seventh
for the d-backs they lead five to one
[Applause]
christian walker belts one deep to left
field and there it goes
number six for walker and it's six to
one
bases loaded walks are nice but home
runs are a lot more fun oh yeah that's
christian's first since august seven
a 440 foot blast to left center field
haven smith knocks it into left field
car shows home at 7-1 martin at third
rbi for pavon
we've seen some gumby shoulders lately
when he's missed pitches he thought he
should have hit shaking his head as he
walks out of the batter's box but real
nice hitting that time
head right down the barrel the bat lines
it into left field aggressive base
running by cattell to go first to third
dalton varshall scores
back base hit to right joe will score
rogers will stop at third
so ryan mcmahon has driven in both runs
today he's two for three and a walk
never know
seven two
this is lifted to right
smith catching tagging and
coming to the plate to score is brennan
rodgers with sac fly for chrome
and it's 7-3
then a big series he did not play in the
game on friday singled and homeward last
night he has doubled in homer today
and sure enough shoots one down the line
he got the slider and jumped on it
peralta's home var show
in it for third hayes got the rbi triple
one strike on connor joe
joe draws this ball to center martigo
back still going back and
this is going to take one hop and go
over the wall so joe
drives in nunez
[Applause]
rojas at shortstop and the diamondbacks
get the win eight to four
you